[Musique]
bonjour, bienvenue à nouveau, je suis heureux que vous ayez
pu me rejoindre aujourd'hui,
plongeons dedans et passons toutes les couleurs sur
l'écran que vous aurez besoin de
peindre avec moi, j'ai ma vieille
toile habituelle ici mouillée et prête à  allez maintenant
, attrapons notre fidèle brosse de deux pouces
ici, enlevez-la un peu
comme si elle vous devait de l'argent, nous allons avoir un
peu de neige humide ou jaune ici mélangez cela
avec juste une autre petite touche de notre
Betty White
maintenant bien c'est  Juste Daniel Sedin, petit ciel heureux,
souviens-toi que c'est ton monde, tu dois
faire et casser les règles ici, doux bébé
Jésus, j'aimerais pouvoir sauter là-dedans et
rouler et toute cette poudre blanche en cascade
ouais, prends de la hauteur et toute
la splendeur de la vie Dieu que j'aime  cocaïne
tellement [ __ ] de [ __ ] de jointure je suis haut comme un
cerf-volant en ce moment d'accord peignons dans quelques
petits arbres heureux il n'y a rien de mal
à se faire des amis avec des arbres vous savez
ce que vous ne voulez pas faire c'est manger ces
peintures faites-moi confiance sur celui-ci  d'accord
je vais marcher  de Ken c'est vrai
ça fait du bien
[Rires
] regarderais-tu qu'il semble que nous
ayons nous-mêmes une peinture finie donc
de notre famille à la tienne garde ton pantalon au
sec tes rêves sont partis et souviens-toi des câlins de la
drogue de la mort
[Musique]